I'm wearing lip gloss that's how you can
tell I'm really trying to give a [ __ ]
like wearing a sports bra made of
tissues I'm making a video for you get
ready for this or just have this thrust
upon you in your unready state I went to
my tumblr to ask you guys what did you
want to see in a video today and so many
of you were asking me to review Taylor
Swift's new album 1989 the cover art of
the album is a point where we're going
to Taylor Swift we think we don't know
can't see the eyes could be anyone with
a cherub lower half of the face and some
red lipstick and trust me there's a
whole bunch of cherub lower halves
running around right now did anyone go
is this for Halloween oh this is a great
post Halloween costume what is the
person that realized on November 1st
that they should have been Barbara
Walters for Halloween saved by Halloween
costumes hindsight is always 20/20 I
have not yet purchased Taylor Swift's
new album 1989 I know I probably will
Elma sheep all mushy on mushy I thought
instead I would listen to the snippets
of tracks that they give you for free on
iTunes before you purchase it with you
guys and make some very rash judgments
on it because I like my judgments like I
like my STDs rash first track welcome to
New York
I have a hard time believing that unless
it's New York the vh1 reality show
Celebrity then maybe she's been waiting
for me
I don't know and if so New York tweet at
me DM me for god sake blank space has
promised
cheap up get a flu shot style I should
say because I
if you don't want the tilt world guy in
your house just get them out out of the
woods did you go to Coachella this year
all you had to do a stay she must have a
dog shake it off got it I wish you would
me
I think this whole album might be about
her relationship with a dog she owned
bad blood oh the dog had blood in its
stool we'll find out yep it did wildest
dreams
did she
I felt sleep with my eyes open for a
second how you get the girl
waiting forever and ever is how it works
it's how you get the girl
we're all gonna die someday so two
thumbs up this love ooh very Enya and
you're not done yet okay
I know places
we run
so like know some illegal [ __ ] going
down the last song on here is called
clean is that just a message to me look
I haven't been in my house for weeks
I know it's dirty you still stage dreads
I can't win you're still over me like a
wine stain dress I can't wear anymore
here are my revamp lyrics you're like a
dress that I realized after the fact
when I put you on in the middle of a
party that you had a wine stain on you
that I didn't notice but I'm just gonna
go with it and quietly pour more wine on
my dress and pretend it's tie-dye oh
that was a bad choice doesn't look that
way
should just tied a cardigan around my
waist I'll learn better next time ooh is
that Pinot Grigio don't mind if I do
where'd the dog come from there we go
there was my review
not too much review is just commentary
on Taylor Swift's new album 1989 uh I'm
gonna be buying it because and it's
purchased okay well you witnessed this I
hope this was enjoyable for you because
this was a time that we had together
where we shared just my thoughts I don't
know hey guys if you like these videos
at all whatsoever you should hit the
subscribe button and also maybe click
like if that's something that you liked
also leave a comment telling me let's
see whoa because I read your comments
spoiler alert I know how to read leave a
comment about how you felt about the
album and um what else oh oh don't
forget okay
Wow let's watch that back oh oh not
flattering but what here is my friend
Mary Hart and I are going on tour for
doing a live comedy show called this
make it weird y'all we're going to Nash
Oh Charlotte Atlanta New Orleans Houston
and tempeh please click the links down
below and get your tickets down because
they're gonna sell out and we're super
excited about this tour there's so many
things that we're doing in it that we
have never done before that's a wrap I
am over trap right now
chicken caesar wrap anybody nobody I'm
by myself still right got it